bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport l'émission
consacrée à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite le sommaire de
votre magazine baseball les cougars de
monty bretons ne se sont imposés contre
les deux fidèles de saint-just ce week
end
des signes montrent à en remporter le
premier match 9 à 2 et le second 13 à 7
les détails dans ce magazine
course à pied les limouxins sidy diallo
s'est lancé le défi de coin son premier
marathon en octobre 2010 à 55 ans parce
que six ans plus tard le sportif en
totalise plus d'une centaine et 9
ultramarathon des compétitions qu'il
pratique pieds nus depuis octobre
dernier
nous recevrons dans ce magazine tennis
les finales de l'open de tennis
d'elancourt était organisée ce samedi au
parc des sports guy boniface le tournoi
était cette année sa 28e édition plus de
350 sportifs se sont inscrits pour la
compétition
et puis nous parlons également de
handball dans cette émission coup de
projecteur aujourd'hui sur l'équipe
masculine senior de plaisir l'épisode
rats sont actuellement deuxième de
prénationale
on commence ce magazine par du baseball
les cougars de montille retenus ont
facilement battu les deux filles dogs de
st juste ce dimanche à domicile le score
9 à 2 dans le premier match est très à 7
dans le second de victoire importante
dans la course à la montée en première
division patrick flores est parfait pour
les images deux matches deux victoires
pour les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux ce dimanche contre les deux
filles dogs de st juste pour le compte
de la 4e journée du championnat de
première division les signé mon teint se
sont imposés à domicile 9 à 2 dans la
première rencontre et 13 à 7 dans la
seconde je pense qu'on a fait un bon
match on a atteint notre objectif
que ce soit personnel ou pour l'équipe
tout le monde est content aujourd'hui
plutôt positif même si on a deux pas
petites choses à corriger un tour encore
à l'entraînement et puis ça doral
c'était vraiment un match comme on dit
de préparation parce que voilà on
voulait c'est une équipe qui valait
beaucoup de base afin qu'ils avaient
l'intention vraiment venir pour gagner
et on s'était un match test c'était
vraiment aussi aujourd'hui une journée
test parce que voilà si on les gagne pas
on aura eu des problèmes au crès je
pense mentalement aussi
c'était vraiment important pour ça de
gagner contre cette équipe-là avec cette
victoire montigné premiers du
championnat à égalité de points avec
l'équipe fédérale de toulouse les deux
équipes affichent un bilan de cinq
victoires et une seule défaite depuis le
début de la saison les statistiques
digne d'un prétendant à la montée en
première division
on prend toujours les match par match a
vraiment les victoires vu par victoire
on va pas s'emballer on reste serein on
reste la tête faut garder la tête froide
pour l'instant la défense et notre
objectif maintenant on a encore beaucoup
de chemin à faire et qu'on n'a pas
affronté tout le monde d'accord on a un
bon objectif on a un bon collectif donc
je pense que c'est faisable
prochain match pour montigny le
bretonneux le dimanche 15 mai sur le
terrain de la rochelle une équipe
invaincue à domicile
sidy diallo 61 ans est un mordu de
course à pied ligne mantes a réalisé en
5 ans et demi 133 marathon et 9
ultramarathon dans 51 pays et sur sept
continents sur l'addiction running et
récente le sportif a débuté le marathon
de 42 km le 10 octobre 2010 à chicago
vous avons la chance de recevoir sur son
plateau si diallo
bonsoir bonsoir google alors pourquoi
vous êtes-vous lancé à dans les
marathons
je le disais c'est en 2010 vous savez on
se lève pas un joueur comme ça hop je
vais courir et mal à thorens et c'est
une langue une courte histoire à la fois
j'ai eu la chance en fait j'étais
affecté comme consul général adjoint de
france à chicago et j'arrive et deux
mois après je devais faire un discours
est bienvenu pour les marathoniens
français qui participent à la course
d'un chicago et on m'avait préparé un
discours qui était un peu administratif
j'ai essayé de fermer les touchent
finalement j'ai dit je vais improviser
et interminable mon discours j'ai dit
mal à tenir marathonienne l'année par
tonne chicago avec vous citez les
docteurs êtes entraînés ça faisait un
peu plus de cinq ans que je m'entraînais
en salle musculation comme ça pour faire
boire la plage comme on dit comme on dit
mais j'ai patiné ma promesse je fais
pour mes seins en 2008 en 2009 j'ai pas
fait le marathon en 2010 finalement deux
mois avant avant le marathon j'ai décidé
que je veux courir le marathon c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut pas faire un
pas deux mois al avance mais moi je le
fais j'ai terminé à 5h20 et c'était très
dur mais j'avais décidé que je ne vais
pas abandonner mon premier marathon
ça commence et je le disais plus de 130
marathon en cinq ans vos proches en
pense quoi de pas tellement une
addiction est une activité normale des
humains puis le 3 millions d'années homo
sapiens et les espèces des hominidés qui
l'ont précédé ont parcouru de longues
distances
aujourd'hui nous avons l'eau et la
nourriture à portée de main mais notre
corps en fait il le fait pour les
épreuves d'endurance
donc vous êtes en train de dire que
c'est naturel c'est naturel c'est
naturel coulé à parcourir de longues
distances c'est naturel pour homo
sapiens donc notre espèce et votre
famille du coup alors là pensez quoi de
cette enchaînement de marathon elle vous
à vous a soutenu dans cette démarche
toulouse a oui oui oui oui oui et au
moins une épouse a même fait notamment
donc choisir les meilleurs marathon pour
l l'autre et martin en australie puis le
marathon aussi de
maritime 42 km entre nice et cannes ont
fait deux tours parce que ça fait moins
de 42 donc on fait en fin de tour pour
aboutir à des kilomètres et vous
entraînez combien de fois par semaine
tous les jours alors terre comme un homo
sapiens le faisait j'ai pas un programme
d'entraînement on n'a pas besoin de
programmes d'entraînement en il suffit
juste de saisir le temps qu'on a
et puis on fait en cours comme on veut
je fais aussi beaucoup d'escalier il ya
des gens qui m'ont peut-être vu à la
gare de saint quentin à gaz colonies vim
elles sont quatre en yvelines en train
de faire les escaliers monter ou
descendre plusieurs fois deux fois dix
fois
en attendant le départ de mon train pour
paris et vous avez abandonné jusqu'à
m'attends également oui alors j'ai
abandonné le bus quand quand j'ai décidé
d'essayer de vraiment faire comme avant
c'est à dire courir le marathon
parcourir de longues distances
mes pieds nus mais quand on l'a mais je
suis quand on a mis des chaussures
pendant toute sa vie où pendant plus de
quatre décennies ce qui était mon cas et
qu'on le décide de d'enlever les
chaussures c'est une preuve
et pourquoi avez vous décidé de donner
vos chaussures pour courir encore une
fois c'est passer du jour au lendemain
l'idée mais je suis parce que c'est la
femme naturelle de marcher et courir ses
pieds nus pieds nus et du coup vous avez
tenté l'expérience agréable si je me
trompe pas oui après une courte
préparation aussi en fait j'aime
beaucoup aller à la casse c'est pas bien
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut pas faire
il faut peut-être au moins un an pour
pouvoir courir le marathon pieds nus m
un an d'entraînement moi ça faisait
quelques mois et puis à zagreb en fait
agréable j'ai décidé de faire à zagreb
parce que ça correspondait au cinquième
anniversaire de mon premier marathon
donc j'ai décidé de le célébrer en
courant le marathon de zagreb pin et il
n'y a pas eu dans dix capes du coup sa
première course si si si elle coûte deux
gars ajouté trahi par l'amitié où il
faisait très froid avait beaucoup de
vent et quand il fait froid en fait on a
froid aux pieds
pas seulement parce que le sol est froid
mais c'est parce que il se produit ce
qu'on appelle une ischémie il ya moins
de sens qui arrive
ce comité aux oreilles ou nez aux pieds
et aux mains
c'est parce que c'est la façon du corps
d'essayer de maintenir à température
internet français degré de keisse froid
il ya moins de 5 et arif est donc comme
ça c'est le sens qui chauffent les
parties donc on a froid et je me suis
rendu compte
g le g3 option mes pieds étaient
tellement lourd on dirait que c'était du
plomb et donc j'avais trois options la
première abandonnés se dit exclue
la deuxième continuer à courir doucement
pour ménager mes pieds mais je lui ce
qu'est les ingénieurs et peut-être la
nécrose des pieds et la troisième option
site et d'accélérer pour produire la
température interne où je fais un peu le
pied du bien à jallais la casse voilà
voilà donc j'ai couru vite et j'ai fini
à moins de 80 et mais je payer très cher
après
je pouvais pas marcher j'ai été obligé
de jouer mais pas mettre mes chaussures
le pied tellement conflit que je peux
pas mettre des chaussures je suis rentré
en chaussettes de de zagreb et mais deux
semaines après ben je fais le marathon
de dublin pieds nus et vous n'êtes plus
dans l'idée de performance de réaliser
un temps où vous êtes dans une idée de
plus taux de participation les gens me
disent ah les assiettes c'est de
participer
non pour le marathon non c'est pas ça
c'est valable pour les gens qui vont
chercher deux médailles et qui l'ont pas
andy l'essentiel c'est de participer
comme aux jeux olympiques
en fait le marathon a un aspect très
particulier c'est que a on a des
professionnels qui font le marathon pour
le gagner le gagner et plus gagner de
l'argent soutenir les familles ils sont
très motivés
depuis l'enfance tout petits ils se
disent quand je serai grand je vais
devenir champion de marathon comme un
brésilien ou peut-être des jeunes d'ici
de 50 ans ils veulent devenir zinedine
zidane thierry henry donc ces gens là
après pour les battre c'est très
difficile ils sont hyper motivés et vend
pour gagner et gagner de l'argent donc
gagner leur vie mais maintenant c'est à
nous autres nous on a mangé on a tout ce
qu'il nous faut en fait on court
seulement on fait semblant de chasse et
on fait semblant qu'on cherche la
nourriture on l'a déjà
donc si on cherche la performance si
c'est une manière de se motiver pour
faire le marathon très bien mais en fait
on ne devait pas faire ça puisque toute
façon va pas gagner comme on veut pas
gagner on n'a pas besoin de gagner on a
de quoi manger
c'est pas la peine donc pour moi c'est
l'expérience qui compte chaque course et
seulement l'expérience je passe mon
temps à discuter avec les gens avaient
discuté avec les coureurs ceux qui sont
en difficulté
j'essaie de les encourager
j'ai fait plusieurs kilomètres avec des
gens y pensent finalement que c'est ma
vitesse alors que nous c'était juste
pour être un temps avec eux pour les
accompagner et c'est qu'ils sont blessés
joie que j'accueille des tendinites
je suis leur donne des conseils et je
discute avec aussi un petit peu le grand
frère de la course cela n'a pas
tellement ça mais juste quelqu'un quand
je fais quelque chose de normal et tout
le monde fait quelque chose de normal
et vous comptez faire des marathons
jusqu'à quel âge vous avez vous est fixé
une date limite en nous disant je sais
pas à 65
quand j'arrêterai oui j'ai une date
limite 200 ans de sa vie non aussi
longtemps que je pourrais faire du matin
je le fais et j'essaie de tout faire
pour conserver cette capacité de faire
des marathons la vitesse va diminuer
c'est normal avec l'âge mais je suis
décidée à continuer voilà et voilà jeu
60e ans et je planche
j'achète des marathons et toutes les
semaines avec des ultramarathons sans
aucun problème mais c'est toujours très
détendue c'est pas la performance et
l'expérience et voilà et quel est votre
prochain marathon mais franchement là
temps je sais je sais pas encore martin
stricto sensu auxquels je me suis
inscrit ses andorre 1 le 7 juillet mais
le 29 le 29 mai j'ai une course un
ultramarathon en afrique du sud
ça s'appelle le koweït le marathon des
camarades qui remonte à la première
édition remonte à 1928 et s'étaient
inscrits voilà je suis inscrit dans tout
ça j'ai prévu de faire cette course là
mais je peux il n'est pas exclu que
dimanche prochain je cours le marathon
de genève
je veux voir ce soir là ce que je veux
faire peut-être que je veux m'inscrire
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
bon courage pour votre prochain d'un
marathon ne sais pas encore on ne
connaît pas encore la destination mais
voilà bon courage en tout cas on passe
maintenant au tennis
les finales de l'open de tennis
d'elancourt était organisée ce samedi au
parc des sports guy boniface le tournoi
fêter cette année sa 28e édition plus de
350 sportifs se sont inscrits pour cette
compétition roma rose fini à pour le
montage des coups droits des amorties
des matches à enjeu le 28e open de
tennis des longs cours a tenu toutes ses
promesses
organisé depuis le 9 avril dernier au
parc des sports guy boniface l'événement
a attiré plus de 377 venus d'île de
france mais également du nord de la
france
c'est un tournant la première catégorie
à 2400 euros de lots donc par exemple
vainqueur messieurs gagne 700 euros
voilà donc il ya quand même un enjeu
financier d'argent à gagner les finales
étaient programmées ce samedi chez les
dames candice paillat de noisy le roi
s'est incliné contre et le début son de
blois après un match accroché le score
4-6 7-6 6-4
elle a très bien vu sur les balles de
match et je suis tendu
de ce que comme j'ai vu que je finissais
pas je me suis détendu dans les moments
tendus et ben je veux plus court donc
j'avais c'est plus vrai que pendant le
match et donc après elle en a profité
et c'est vrai qu'elle a quatre balles de
match après je les les jours je les joue
et bon j'ai un petit peu de chance la
chance et non cotés après c'est vrai que
voilà le match peut très bien être en sa
faveur et elle mérite totaux tout autant
que moi donc là dessus là dessus voilà
c'est je m'en sors mais je m'en sors ans
en allant un peu au culot comme on dit
chez les hommes rudy coco originaire de
beaune favori du tournoi a remporté
l'épreuve pour la troisième année
consécutive le tennisman s'est imposé en
deux sets 6-1 7-6 contre éric forbach du
tc plaisir
l'équipe senior de plaisir est
actuellement la deuxième place du
classement de prénationale dans la poule
paris ile de france ouest l'équipe
pointe à deux points de paris sport club
à quatre journées de la fin du
championnat pour nous parler du club
nous recevons sur ce plateau à benjamin
modeste guillaume gauthier et les
l'équipe et le pivot stéphane maruto
bonsoir alors cette deuxième place c'est
une satisfaction ou c voilà tout
simplement le minimum syndical début de
saison l'objectif n'est pas la montée
que le groupe a été vraiment construit
une oeuvre départ donc voilà on est
trois arrivées très bon joueur mais
voilà il ya les jeunes qui poussent
derrière
on visait le haut de tableau forcément
mais voilà arrivés à deux semaines à je
parie pour la première place oui
forcément il ya de la déception derrière
mais un peu moins que les nains
vous êtes d'accord oui surtout après le
match qu'on fait à paris on fait un non
match
l'ensemble de l'équipe paris a joué son
match complètement et c'est ça qui est
décevant quoi d'ailleurs
l'année dernière vous avez raté la
montée a très peu la différence de buts
si je me trompe pas oui oui en fait on a
raté le but on a raté le but de la
montée à dernière seconde on a nos
joueurs qui a eu un petit loupé c'est
comme ça merci guillaume mais sinon et
dernière et hier c'était très dur et
loin but pour un goût ce serait une
vraie déception si vous montez pas cette
année deux années de suite si proche du
but finalement et
vous montez bah c'est pas deux années de
suite c'est ça doit être dix fois en 12
ans 12-13 ans bon on va dire qu'on est
un petit peu habitués à cette place
après mois pour moi c'est une vraie
déception surtout campus j'arrive un
petit peu en fin de carrière contre un
mois à mes deux acolytes
maintenant faut enfin pour être l'être
un pari cette année puis fort que nous
deux matches deux victoires pour eux
benjamin quand vous l'expliquer ce
problème justement de finir toujours
toujours deuxièmes ou à la limite de la
montée comme le dit stéphane enfin un
problème c'est la déstructuration être
non je pense pas non puisque les joueurs
ont vraiment envie le la vie du club
voilà avec le coach on s'entend tous
très bien il ya vraiment aucun souci je
n'ai pas l'année dernière ça s'est
vraiment joué voilà un bus est très
bonne c'est vraiment une saison complète
pour nous et ne pas être monté les
dernières rsa salut viendra qumran mais
de voir ce qu'on fait cette année encore
une fois avec de nouveaux joueurs
voilà un faux faut jamais un faux pas
lâcher pour l'avenir l'année prochaine
au volant on va repartir avec cet
objectif la montée comme comme johnny
les caissières manqué cette année
finalement à plaisir pas mal même si la
montée n'est pas encore il sera
abandonné
je n'ai pas définitivement abandonnée
mais c'est bien parti pour paris pour
l'accession à la nationale 3 après on a
eu pas mal de blessés aussi en début de
saison on perd david potard qui se met
le genou milieu de saison on a
john qui se fait l'épaule qui était très
fort à notre bras armé de l'équipe
c'était notre grosse erreur donc plus
voilà les jeunes qui arrivent qui se
forme avec nous et c c'est compliqué
stéphane vous êtes la meilleure attaque
du championnat avec 562 buts inscrits la
meilleure attaque du championnat la
deuxième meilleure défense comment
comment l'expliquez où justement ce
problème il faudra faire plus c'est
l'année prochaine alors plus on peut
toujours faire plus il faut quand même
savoir que difficile il faut relativiser
dans la mesure où si on reste si on en
reste là ne pas monter avec deux
défaites c'est ce qu'on a fait l'année
dernière
il faut savoir qu'il y a énormément de
saison on en serait monté et unis ont
mis beaucoup de saisons au premier est
monté avec trois quatre défaites dont on
fait quand même des saisons assez plein
depuis deux ans après faire plus c'est
pas simple on peut toujours faire plus
se dire qu' il vaut peut-être mieux la
meilleure défense je suis pas totalement
d'accord tu que pendant des années on a
eu la meilleure défense et on n'est pas
pu se monter là ça fait deux saisons ou
offensivement
on n'est pas mal non plus non elle va
finir par trouver la solution après je
vois pas grand chose jabra il faudra une
nouvelle équipe l'année prochaine vous
voulez reconstruire continue avec les
joueurs qui sont en place le staff qui
remplace donc le tout reste en place
pour moi et que on est de trois arrivées
de joueurs ayant un peu de bouteille et
de un très bon niveau de ventes bonne
parce qu'aujourd'hui si on repart avec
cinq six joueurs qui est qui qui s'en
vont cinq six joueurs qui arrivent mais
repart à zéro quoi ton temps de bosser
et que tout se met en place
on arrive au mois d'octobre décembre et
puis voilà on a déjà quatre mois de
retard là si on garde le même effectif
pour moi voilà on va être très
compétitifs l'année prochaine mais je
trouve que le niveau ne en mieux les
prochaines y aura toujours métro il
renversa y aura roissy aura val de seine
fin ça va être très costaud donc il faut
conduire le même effectif et cours coûte
manqué d'expérience dans ce groupe
finalement l'expérience non je pense pas
parce que le sept de base 101 7 qui a
vécu pas mal de choses dans le handball
équipe pas si jeune que ça
après c'est vrai qu'elle est jeune mais
qui nous apporte aujourd'hui pas mal et
compte très bien évolué depuis le début
de saison
prêts pour l'année prochaine c'est con
si on continue sur la même lancée je
pense que comme une image amant sera
compétitif avec des renforts ce sera que
mieux il reste quatre matches avant la
fin de la saison
vous allez les jouer à fond où vous
allez peut-être intégrer à des jeunes
pour qu'ils prennent de l'expérience en
vue la saison prochaine il faut savoir
que l'intégration des jeunes elle a été
fait déjà depuis la saison par
l'entraîneur après enfin que ce soit
enfin moi mais mes coéquipiers ou
l'entraîneur partir moment mon impulsion
de terrain nous pour gagner donc les
quatre matches on va les jouer à fond
comme l'année dernière les avait joué à
fond
et ça on ne laissera pas la place je ne
sais quel l'amusement votre vos chances
de montée mais d'ici là combien 2 0%
là maintenant de 0,5 pour cent a vu le
chemin de paris
les équipes qui sans dénigrer des
équipes qui dès qu'il reste à jouer
voilà je les vois pas perdre ils ont
fait plusieurs en nous battant battant
versailles embêtant en allant gagner à
roissy et en battant métro voilà donc je
pense qu'ils ont ils ont fait ce qu'il
fallait faire moi je les vois pas perdre
ce qu'il faut qu'ils perdent deux fois
parce qu'après si on ex-aequo et nous
ils nous battent à la différence de buts
particulière
je les vois pas perdre deux matches mais
nous continuons à saint andré n'est pas
beaucoup d'autres tableaux merci à tous
les trois des patients ce plateau vous
souhaite de réaliser une grosse fin de
saison est un peu de chance d'avoir un
peu de chance également pour que paris à
perdre zuma présents sur la plage à la
piscine de saint cyr l'école pourrait
être témoin d'un record mondial andy
cabreira avila a s'est lancé le défi de
pâques war plus de 9 km en apnée pendant
six heures chaque longueur effectué et
permettra de récolter 1 euro pour
financer un exosquelette pour aider un
enfant de 10 ans à se dépasser
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images un record risque de tomber à la
piscine municipale de saint cyr l'école
le dimanche 22 mai andy cabreira à biya
un apnéiste de 45 ans d'origine cubaine
va tenter de parcourir la plus grande
distance possible on appelait pendant
six heures pour cela le sportif devra
effacer le record de pascal maes et le
français effectués 9,3 km le 7 février
dernier pour le battre andy s'entraîne
au minimum deux fois par semaine depuis
trois mois à la fois intense et la plus
dure la plus difficile c'est la gestion
de l'effort
on n'a pas encore
l'alliance entre les faits six heures
malgré le choc et je m'hydrate tous les
30 minutes
je m'arrête pour une minute et ses
déboires mais là tu es avec des lots
sucre et de l'eau et des sels minéraux
un record pour la bonne cause chaque
longueur effectué et permettra de
récolter 1 euro pour financer un
exosquelette pour aider luna une enfant
de 10 ans victime d'une infirmité
motrice cérébrale la combinaison pour
lui permettre de se déplacer et en
combinaisons que coûte 6000 nouveaux
sociale cette combinaison permet aux
jeunes handicapés d améliorer leur
motricité
donc elle accouchait luna c'est mon
élève c'est une copine et garder
magnifique corbeille mais pascal mazet
mais pas ringo pour n'importe quoi se
compose ses les champions des capitaux
mais des rancoeurs pendant ses séances
d'entraînement dit cabreira via réussi à
parcourir la même distance que le
précédent record en seulement trois
heures et 13 minutes on passe maintenant
l'essentiel de l'actualité yvelinoise on
commence à trouver que par du football
américain dans le championnat élite les
templiers à del en course en une spirale
négative les footballeurs en perdu ce
dimanche sur le terrain des gladiateurs
de la queue-en-brie le score 8 à 0 une
sixième défaite consécutive qui propulse
les tant pis à la dernière place du
classement synonyme de descente en
deuxième division
on écoute le directeur sportif des
templiers afrique par jour le nom est
complètement ultérieure
on va rencontrer lent qu'un jour une
équipe est le même nombre de victoires
que nous finalement nous occupe est
vraiment voiture de maman ou mal à
occuper le hameau de golf à présent le
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines a rouvert ce samedi le parcours
de l'albatros après neuf mois de
fermeture pour travaux
pour l'occasion un événement baptisé
11bouge été organisée au programme un
concours de précision des animations
avec l'ancien joueur de l'european tour
david edwards ce niveau du trou numéro
11 plus de mille amateurs étaient
présents on écoute le responsable du
golf national paul hermitage
il nous présente les objectifs de cette
journée c'est de dire aux gens ben voilà
on ré ouvre en est ouvert venez
découvrir parce qu'il faut redémarrer la
machine pour nous on a on n'a pas pu
accueillir ses clients pendant des mois
maintenant il faut qu'on fasse une
opération de séduction pour qu'il
revienne c'est la face aux 7,8 sport
merci d'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine à 10
il a passé une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv fil 78